so welcome and thank you everyone
this morning my name is Riley Hart again
I'm
by my colleagues Meredith Crawford and
Laurie Toth and we're here to talk a
little bit about JIRA and confluence and
how at the Yale School of Management we
use that beyond IT and for things that
are not technical so non-traditional
uses of JIRA and confluence perfect much
better so before we begin I just want to
kind of gauge who's in the audience so
if you have used JIRA or confluence
before go ahead and raise your hand
shout at me okay
so perfect how about the other questions
- any of these apply to you you've you
know haven't been able to find an email
when you've needed to like get some
information you feel like you have an
ever-growing to-do list and finally
since we're in New Haven how many of you
like pizza yes okay awesome awesome
round of applause when you hear the
pizza so pizza comes in
and finally from what we learned so wo
let's dig in literally its up and this
is where the funny story concepts so a
lot of algae to spread workflows and but
we're going to Majan that we're all
gonna eat cereal okay
and we have to do a certain amount of
things to get a pizza from somewhere
during at
right so we're gonna build a basic Pizza
Tracker and that's just someone places
an order it's crap so there's a customer
one of you places in an order one of you
is putting the toppings on that pizza he
puts it in the oven the other chefs
edits goes in the box
delivers it and someone's lucky enough
to go to that keeps up and now that we
have this beautiful piece of cracker we
can see we're doing pretty color
material right we can see working in all
quarters so really that simple and if
things are going on in the show and
we're able to immediate issue because we
built this and here we got our customers
saying yeah where's my pizza and you
have a manager saying what's going on
and thankfully because you've built this
keep the tracker we can see maybe where
these issue is so there are no pieces in
the other it's probably a problem
because it means you have no pieces and
boxes between
and now for the really embarrassing
so basically I think batteries of that
can you hear me now
perfect alright so to come full circle
what are JIRA and confluence JIRA is
basically a Pizza Tracker so we can see
a basic workflow into your to-do in
progress and done and we just built a
custom workflow for a non-traditional
use of JIRA with our pizza tracker we
have ordered place our in progress
statuses with prep baking box up for
delivery and then finally a resolution
of done and I'm using some of these
words because again a lot of you are
familiar with your in confluence so now
that we've gone through that we can
finally come full circle and explain the
analogy so in this story of our pizzeria
JIRA is really the pizza tracker it's
tracking those items along that workflow
JIRA Service Desk is kind of
embarrassing lis again like that
Domino's Pizza Tracker it's really where
the customer is seeing you know where's
my pizza how long is it going to take to
get to me what's the status of that
pizza and and finally confluence is a
place where we can all collaborate great
pizza recipes write guidelines about how
we work and finally a pizza can be
anything that you'd like in JIRA so to
talk about those any things in JIRA I'm
gonna hand it over now to my colleagues
Meredith who's gonna talk a little bit
about what those things are at the Yale
School of Management thanks Riley hi I'm
Meredith Crawford I handle editorial
workflow for the communications
department at som and that's a slide
here some of you might recognize this as
a basic screenshot of a base camp before
we found JIRA and confluence as a
workflow solution we were using Basecamp
which I think a lot of editorial teams
probably do and we were using it to
manage our communications projects which
at any given time we probably have
dozens of and they ranging complex
so some of them are really
straightforward they don't require a lot
of you know a lot of a complicated
workflow they just go from to do to in
progress to done but some of them have a
lot of different assets a lot of
stakeholders a lot of creators and and
also we have a built in process where we
need to send our content out to external
external stakeholders for approval so in
addition to that we also have a post
publish so once our work is published we
also have a another workflow to consider
and that's how to promote our content on
social and maybe how to create something
on the website to feature it more
prominently and when we were doing all
of these things in Basecamp we were
really limited when it came to
differentiating the various tasks within
one project everything had to be under
one umbrella and so we would end up with
these huge threads that sometimes went
on for months at a time and I mean you
can see at the top of here we have three
hundred and three thousand five hundred
eighty discussions so you'd have to mine
your way through that and then when you
were working on a project say you're
looking for a specific asset like a
video you would have to go through the
thread and you know god forbid you
pulled the wrong video not the most
updated Word document so it was really
confusing and we quickly realized that
it would be great if we can find a
workflow solution that gave us a 360
degree view of our projects a place
where we could keep everything under one
umbrella but also take into account that
all of the various tasks and assets
probably had their own like sort of
workflow to take it into account
so this is where JIRA came into play and
this is just the very very bare-bones
basic sort of baked in JIRA workflow
that that everybody has access to really
and that is just you know gives you a
very simplified workflow to do in
progress and done so we started with
this and we realized pretty quickly that
we had almost limitless options in terms
of
customizing our workflow process for all
of our needs which is great but it's
also a little daunting so we spent a lot
of time really dialing in and trying to
figure out what we needed what we didn't
need and eventually for the editorial
side we came up with this and you'll see
it still includes some of the very basic
very basic statuses that you would get
in a simplified workflow like open you
know the project is hasn't been started
assigned it's in draft mode we have when
we're working on something we need it to
be sent out for external approval to a
stakeholder so that's a status that we
decided we needed and then you know
ready to be put into the CMS published
and done so this has worked really well
for us
and it allows us to take into account
every point that we move content through
and to bring it from creation to
completion and this also allows us to
include post publishing concerns like
social media promotion and the best part
is that when we create a ticket to begin
working on a project we can incorporate
all the elements that go along with it
so just by adding subtasks we can
consider various assets like if it has a
video if it has photos that we need you
know we need to promote it on social
that kind of thing and everything is
kept in one place which is great and in
terms of keeping it all organized this
is probably my favorite thing about JIRA
this is so this is a Kanban I don't know
how many people are familiar with that
if you're not familiar with JIRA it's I
like to think of it as a very
non-technical person so I like to think
of it as just kind of a blackboard where
everything gets aggregated and you can
really can really keep it organized by
creating these quick filters which are
when you label content you can then dial
in and search by the quick filter and
you can see that everything is in its
own column so we have stuff
but still waiting to be done we have
stuff that's in progress someone's
reviewing it someone's working on
writing it we have stuff that's out for
approval we have stuff that's ready for
CMS and then we have stuff that's
published and what you don't see on that
is there are also some some other
customizable tasks within that that say
whether or not it's ready for social or
if it has been promoted on social or not
so we've really really gotten pretty
granular with that customization my
favorite thing about the quick filters
is that you can click on any of them and
it will just give you the relevant
content so I was in a meeting with our
MBA for executives colleagues the other
day and we're talking about content that
was going to go into their newsletter
and they said what do you what do you
guys have in progress or that you've
recently published that we can use in
the newsletter and I said oh give me a
second I just clicked on the EM book
content label and it gives me every
single thing that has been published and
it tells you exactly what status it's in
so you know is it is it out for approval
has it just been published have we
promoted it on social so that's all
really great I'm happy to talk about
that later and at this point I'm gonna
turn things over to our colleague Lori
he's gonna talk a little bit about how
we use complex nice so I'm gonna talk
about how and why we use confluence we
discovered early on that confluence is a
great place for content planning and
storing meeting notes and we also soon
discovered it's a great place to
collaborate with in the past year we
started to rely on confluence for
content planning it's an easy place for
multiple people from teams across al som
to collaborate on one planning document
it also helps with organization because
we can keep all the notes and
discussions in one area that everyone
can access instead of in someone's email
which might get lost or forgotten at
least in my email
it also makes it easy to keep historical
records this helps if your area runs on
cycles like ours with a few key events
like commencement or conferences that
happen each year by organizing and
keeping our notes we can look back on
what we did the previous year
determine if it worked well and then
planned for the current year
now speaking of planning we tend to do a
lot of that for social media we use a
planning document which helps us track
what's shareable and when we plan to
share it each Monday or social team
meets to discuss the week ahead since we
use HootSuite to schedule content we can
decide what makes sense to post on
twitter facebook Instagram and LinkedIn
and then schedule it once an item is
scheduled we can tick off the box to
indicate that it's done we also have a
section where we keep track of items
that are ready to share it's been
extremely helpful to keep these lists to
remind us of new stories blogs or even
media mentions of faculty that we
haven't shared yet we found that we are
able to be more thoughtful on posts by
being proactive and planning rather than
being reactive so as I mentioned we use
confluence a lot for editorial planning
from social - newsletters to
publications it makes it easier to
communicate and collaborate with
multiple teams
it also helps increase the transparency
of a project and pretty much what our
team is working on each month the
communications team helps send for
individual newsletters for different
admissions teams once we added this
calendar to confluence it helped
everyone realize that their project is
just one of many that we're working on
concurrently it also helps us plan
deadlines and hopefully keeps the
newsletter spaced apart so that we're
not in newsletter planning overload at
any one time of the month we'll see
so this is our newsletter planning
document that Meredith referenced so
when we meet with the admissions teams
we use this document to plan the content
for the month by using a template helps
organize the planning process once the
content is laid out we can track the
progress of the stories many already
have JIRA tickets but anything that's
unique content for the newsletter we
will create a JIRA ticket now we can
keep track of when an item submitted for
review and where it is in the approval
process in this example alone in that
last column of notes you can see we have
some items that are published done
editing or in progress
I'm very heavy-handed in this you can
also prompt milestones like we did for
the newsletters once the check is
performed we can tick the box for
newsletters it serves as a reminder of
the steps that need to be taken before
the newsletter can be sent so this is a
look just briefly of our collaboration
space you can see we use it for print
publications and alumni webinars -
website edits and analytics we chose to
keep our collaborations in one project
but you can break them out into separate
projects that only a certain team can
collaborate in that space if that works
better for you so this has just been a
quick run-through of how and why we use
confluence I am going to send it back to
Riley for some tips all right Thank You
Laurie so I'm gonna go ahead and wrap
things up we've taken a few bites out of
this presentation
starting being a little cheesy but now
I'm gonna go ahead and pick you get some
advice for teams wanting to do the same
you know want to go in and use JIRA and
confluence for these non-technical uses
or you know really beyond IT and the
first and foremost piece of advice I can
give you is to keep it simple especially
to start and what that means are those
workflows that you saw that Meredith
presented that first one that said to do
in progress done and that all of the
statuses can transition to that status
that's what keeping it simple means get
the folks we're going to be using this
habituated to using the tool with a
simple workflow that's open for those of
you whose be Kira and I would also keep
in mind you know think about their use
case think about how you're going to
provide value for that person to you it
was in to adopt confluence in JIRA how
is it going to make their job easier I
think that's something that we learned
along the way next is of course do it
with the legwork and this can mean many
things
this could mean you know doing the
legwork to get buy-in from leadership
and a great way to do that is go to
Atlassian website sign up for a trial
build a workflow show what's possible
and then once you do that instead of
just you know hey we should do this if
you build it and people really see
what's possible they kind of start to
buy in a little bit more and next find
champions and this could be people from
around the school around the university
outside the university so really anyone
who's going to go I didn't jump into
JIRA jump into confluence and into these
tools with you
and I must say you yourself if you are
driving adoption of this tool you need
to take that first jump you need to be
transparent you need to just go in and
start using it start doing your work
there and people will follow especially
when they start to see some of the
benefits that you might know and want to
communicate to your team and again make
sure it's the right solution for your
team this was a great solution for us
because of course these Atlassian tools
have a large footprint already at the
Yale School of Management we're already
using them
we have licenses so hey why not use it
for non traditional or non IT uses
Atlassian themselves actually do this so
really it just made sense
it almost became like a lingua franca
between you know our users our folks in
my department the folks who support us
and our developers we could all kind of
speak this common language of tira and
finally remember that no tool is going
to solve all your problems you know the
tool is only as strong as those
underlying principles kind of
undergirding it so remember that you
know this tool isn't to replace
conversation face to face or
conversations or communication in any
other manner and no matter how cool or
flashy or what kind of automations you
can do again keep it simple to start
with don't overwhelm folks including
yourself if you're driving adoption and
again really remember this last point
and with that we are ready for questions
which I'm sure you might have a lot of
so and the first answer that is handsome
Dan in the Evans Hall courtyard
[Music]